ideal conceal is a Minnesota startup
which has designed a gun that looks like
a smartphone complete with a fake camera
lens and headphone jack their marketing
materials say smartphones are everywhere
so your new pistol will easily blend in
with today's environment from soccer
moms to professionals of every type this
gun allows you the option of not being a
victim now if you're watching along with
us you see the picture of the gun in its
enclosed smartphone disguise and it's
open gun status I guess you would say it
has a small handle that pops out when
the pistol safety is opened and it is
ready to fire with one click according
to the manufacturer the pistol which has
the exact same dimensions of a Samsung
Galaxy s7 phone is currently priced at
$395 but it won't be available until
later this year the pistols developer
Kirk kelberg told NBC affiliate kare11
that he's already already received about
four thousand enquiries from people who
want to buy the smartphone like guns
he holds a concealed carry permit in
Minnesota he said he was once walking
through a restaurant with his regular
gun shaped gun when a child too became
frightened and it gave him the idea that
there might be a better way to have
people walk around with guns but not
frighten kids so I can see the headlines
now Louis unarmed man shot while holding
a phone in a way that it looked like it
could have been a smartphone gun police
weren't sure Louis and they had to take
him out he actually was just trying to
call in a takeout order or film the
police that were he was encountering I
would yeah using your kit the camera on
your phone to record police officers
potentially committing crimes is about
to become a lot more dangerous when it
could be a smartphone looking gun and
this was my first thought this could be
a it's it's almost as if it's already
too late this story has gone viral and
once this is on the mind yeah of all the
police
just this is really really bad if you
have one of these smartphone guns is the
equivalent of a pocket dial shooting
yourself in the ass it would be that it
would be yeah well you don't want to
know what this what the smartphone gun
equivalent of a selfie is I'll tell you
it is it is ugly mm-hmm
that's good one Dave yes and I fully
predict that there will be if this
product actually hits the market that we
are going to hear some real gems about
it I'll we already have right that this
is a good way not to frighten kids who
are going to be around guns it's
especially great for families with young
children now children won't be afraid to
see that Mommy has a gun in her purse or
about why she carries a gun with her all
the time because of the very dangerous
world around her and now that kid thinks
they're reaching for a cellphone
instead it's a gun and and boom
something bad happens as we know toddler
is responsible for more deaths in 2015
via guns than terrorists in the United
States as soon as those kids start
getting into screen time just way that
number is going to skyrocket no doubt
about it